[Music]
so contact POI is a contact juggling
ball on the end of a thick tether with a
ball handle this lets you get into all
kinds of technical juggling and
yumminess which I've never actually done
much of uh although I've admired people
who do like Ronin um since I saw Ronin
doing contact poy at ejc like 10 years
ago I've really admired it so if it's
your thing homop poy has some great
options and they sell them in packs of
three now if you're really a juggler
they even come with really well done
check this out where the swivel is
coming right out of the handle that is
slick so that means opens you up to the
wonderful world of orbitals Etc with
these nice ball bearing
swivels um and all that so if you want
to get if you want to go
technical this is badass and you can
order them sets of three so Tada you
know they've got lots of colors choose
from and different different thicknesses
of rope and different thicknesses of
balls um so I'm going to link to the
whole
section and use playo as your referral
code because you say 5% and then I also
get commission and then that gives me
all the more incentive and I feel
supported in making all the videos I
make so yeah get yourself some contact
boy let me know how it
[Music]
goes